1 vous le disions donc décidé de
répliquer en promettant de fournir des
armes à kiev l'union européenne va
débloquer 450 millions d'euros je vous
propose tout de suite d'écoutés le chef
de la diplomatie européenne josep
borrell
nous voulons tout faire pour soutenir
l'ukraine nous avons décidé d'utiliser
nos capacités pour fournir des armes des
armes létales une assistance létale à
l'armée ukrainienne pour une valeur de
450 millions et 50 millions
supplémentaires pour les fournitures non
létales seins nus carburant ou des
équipements de protection reich feo
et une réunion des ministres de la
défense de l'union européenne a lieu
aujourd'hui pour convertir ce
financement en armement et les acheminer
vers la ligne de front des forces armées
ukrainiennes bruno daroux c'est une
décision historique a pris la l'union
européenne pour aider l'ukraine la
supporter concrètement avec des armes
oui c'est une décision en tout cas très
importante un qui montrent que pour la
première fois de son histoire au ce la
faute des ryan l'a d'ailleurs souligné
l'union européenne fournit des armes un
pays qui est agressé par un autre état
donc l'union européenne à l'occasion de
cette crise est arrivée à surmonter ses
dissensions internes a fait montre d'une
grande unité l'allemagne a également
franchi un tournant historique quand
même avec la décision de se doter
véritablement d'une armée en bonne et
due forme donc entre cette annonce de
l'allemagne le fait que l'union
européenne fournit des armes offensives
y compris d'ailleurs papa défensive
seulement et bien effectivement là on a
une une une europe qui s'affirme un peu
désormais comme une puissance ce que des
dirigeants comme emmanuel macron
justement appelé de leurs voeux depuis
des années et évidemment ça renforce
aussi le fait que l'europe pourrait
aller vers cette fameuse autonomie
stratégique cher là encore au président
français on l'a entendu au début de ce
journal un volodymyr zen qui le
président ukrainien qui demande à
l'union européenne d'accélérer pour que
l'ukraine adhère
on y croit pas forcément alors en fait
volodymyr zelensky lui de toute façon il
joue sa survie donc
il avait réclamé de l'aide aux européens
ils là il l'a obtenue notamment de
l'aide militaire maintenant il pousse le
bouchon un peu plus loin et demandent de
faire partie du club de l'union
européenne ce qui évidemment est à un
autre chiffon rouge pour moscou alors du
coup il place les européens dans une
position un peu délicate parce qu'ils
vont devoir répondre à cette annonce ils
vont sans doute expliquer que les
procédures d'adhésion à l'union
européenne sont très longues mais il ya
quand même une procédure qui fait que
les 27 membres du conseil de l'union
européenne peuvent accepter de recevoir
le dossier d'adhésion en soutient toutes
les procédures qui prennent du temps
mais on peut accélérer un peu les
procédures mais s'ils reçoivent ce
dossier d'adhésion ça veut dire qu'ils
acceptent sur le principe que l'ukraine
rejoigne l'union européenne je pense
qu'ils vont y réfléchir à deux fois
avant de répondre parce que évidemment
ça ne va pas faire plaisir du tout du
tout à vladimir poutine